"THE FIVE" ."
AFTER NEARLY TWO WEEKS OF
GRIPES, GOODBYE, BRENDA SNIPES.
SHE RESIGNS AFTER THE FLORIDA
SENATE RACE ENDS.
MEANWHILE, STACEY ABRAMS ASKED
THE SELF OBSESSED KNOBS OF
HOLLYWOOD NOT TO BOYCOTT GEORGIA
BECAUSE SHE LOST.
SOME STARS HAVE THREATENED TO
BOYCOTT THE STATE BECAUSE THE
VOTE THAT MADE BRIAN KEMP THE
WINNER STILL STANDS.
RON PERLMAN, ALYSSA MILANO,
BRADLEY WHITFORD, GEORGIA IS
REALLY GOING TO MISS YOU GUYS.
NOW WE KNOW HOW TO KEEP OFFICE
HOLLYWOOD CRYBABIES OUT OF OUR
STATE.
WIN ELECTIONS.
THIS IS A BETTER INCENTIVE THAN
LOWER TAXES AND SAFER STREETS.
A VOTE FOR A REPUBLICAN MEANS
ALEC BALDWIN WON'T PUNCH LOCALS
IN THE FACE.
A VOTE AGAINST THE LEFTIST MEANS
YOU'LL NEVER RUN INTO JIM CARREY
WEEPING IN THE PARK.
BUT CLEARLY THIS IS ANOTHER
TANTRUM DISGUISED AS A
PRINCIPLED STAND.
IT'S EASY TO BOYCOTT SOMETHING
YOU DON'T NEED.
SOMETHING TELLS ME MS. MILANO OR
MR. PERLMAN DIDN'T HAVE
LUCRATIVE PROJECTS LINED UP IN
SAVANNAH.
IT'S PURE DESTRUCTIVE
SELFISHNESS.
LET'S PUSH BOYCOTTS THAT DON'T
AFFECT ME THAT HARMS THE ECONOMY
THAT SUPPORTS MILLIONS OF
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS.
I WILL JUST STAY IN BEL AIR.
I STILL GET TO A VIRTUAL SIGNAL
ON TWITTER.
BOYCOTTING A STATE IS AN EVEN
SADDER VERSION OF "I'M MOVING TO
CANADA" BECAUSE EVEN IF THEY
SNEAK INTO GEORGIA, THEY WOULD
NEVER MOVE TO CANADA.
IT'S FAR EASIER TO BOYCOTT A
BODY OF WORK THAN A BODY OF LAND
EVERYONE CAN DO IT AND ONCE THEY
START IN ANYTHING BEYOND A
TWEET, GEORGIA IS GOING TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS TOO.
JUAN, HOW CAN WE NOT PLEASE YOU
GUYS.
YOU DIDN'T GET A BLUE WAVE,
LET'S FACE IT.
CLOSE TO 40 SEATS.
SHOULD BE HAPPY.
I WOULD BE HAPPY.
BUT THEY ARE STILL MAD.
THEY ARE GOING BOYCOTT GEORGIA.
>> Juan: DID YOU MISS
CHRIS WALLACE'S INTERVIEW WITH
DONALD TRUMP?
>> Greg: I DID.
I WAS OUT DRINKING.
I WAS LATE COMING HOME.
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRE
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRI
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRT
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRS
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRI
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRD
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRH
>> Juan: >> Juan: THE PRE
WON, HE WON THE SENATE.
AND THAT'S WHAT COUNTS.
CHRIS SAID WHAT ABOUT THE HOUSE?
HE SAID NO, NO, YOU DIDN'T HEAR
ME.
WE WON.
WE WON THE SENTENCE.
>> Greg: HE IS BEING AN
OPTIMIST BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE
THE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL MAD.
THEY ARE STILL ANGRY, EVEN
WINNING THAT MANY STATES.
HOW MANY GOVERNORSHIPS?
>> Juan: YOU ARE CONFUSING
WHAT HAPPENED IN GEORGIA.
IT WASN'T THE SENATE SEAT IN
GEORGIA.
IT WAS THE GOVERNORSHIP.
THERE YOU SEE STACEY ABRAMS SAME
BRIAN KEMP WHO WAS ALSO
SECRETARY OF STATE SOMEHOW
MANAGED TO PUSH PEOPLE OUT.
>> Greg: WHAT I AM SAYING IS
YOU CAN'T WIN THEM ALL, SO DON'T
BE A SORE LOSER.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT'S KIND
OF DIRTY TACTICS.
>> Greg: OKAY, ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THEM IN THE
MONOLOGUE THAT YOU TOO ADMITTED
YOU GET FACIALS.
>> Dana: WANTED TO ASK HOW YOU
LIKED THE DEAN PACED FACIAL?
>> Jesse: I USUALLY GO WITH
PUMPKINS BY SPATIAL.
>> Greg: ARE YOU GOING TO
MS. MS. SNIPES?
>> Jesse: SHE RETIRED.
I'M SURE SHE WILL POP UP
SOMEWHERE ON MY FEET.
I WILL MISS HER DEARLY.
I THINK DEMOCRATS ALWAYS EXPECT
TO WIN.
THEY LIVE IN A BUBBLE, A SOCIAL
BUBBLE AND THE MEDIA BUBBLE.
THEY THINK CONTROLLING
GOVERNMENT AS THEIR RIGHTFUL
DESTINY BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THEY ARE PROGRESSIVES AND ITS
PROGRESS.
ALSO THEY BELIEVE THEIR WHOLE
GOVERNING PHILOSOPHY IS ABOUT
CONTROLLING GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
CHARGE AND THEN DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE THIS IS LIFE AND DEATH.
GOOD VERSUS EVIL.
SO WHEN THEY LOSE, I MEAN, IT'S
A SOUL CRUSHING LOSS.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE TO QUESTION
EACH LOSS AND SAY IT'S
ILLEGITIMATE.
IT'S LIKE THERAPY FOR THEM.
MOST REPUBLICANS, WHEN THEY WIN,
DEMOCRATS DON'T THINK THEY ARE
LEGITIMATE AT ALL.
IF YOU GO BACK, LOOK AT BUSH IN
2000, TRUMP IN 2016, LOOK AT ALL
THE GOVERNOR WALKER.
THEY QUESTIONED HIS LEGITIMACY.
EVERYTHING ON TIME THERE IS AN
EXCUSE FROM DEMOCRATS.
IT'S GERRYMANDERING.
IT'S RACISM.
IT'S SEXISM.
IT'S THE RUSSIANS.
IT'S VOTER SUPPRESSION.
HILLARY CLINTON, 60 EXCUSES FOR
HER LOSS.
SO IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF
THINGS, YOU LOOK IN FLORIDA AND
YOU THINK THE LAST COUPLE
ELECTIONS THERE, YOU'VE HAD TONS
OF SHENANIGANS BY PEOPLE LIKE
SNEAKY SNIPES.
BALLOTS WERE DESTROYED.
BALLOTS WERE MISCOUNTED.
THEY FOUND BALLOTS.
THINGS WERE DONE IN SECRET, AND
NOW JUDGES HAVE TO COME IN AND
SAY KNOCK IT OFF.
REPUBLICANS SAY THINGS ARE
GETTING FISHY.
THIS COULD BE SOME KIND OF ROD
TAKING PLACE, AND THEN
REPUBLICANS ARE CAST AS
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
HOW DARE YOU QUESTION AN
ELECTION.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLL, 67%
OF DEMOCRATS, 67% BELIEVE THAT
RUSSIANS TAMPERED WITH VOTES TO
ELECT DONALD TRUMP IN 2016.
THAT'S JUST FALSE.
BOTH WERE NEVER TAMPERED WITH.
YET TWO-THIRDS OF DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE IN THAT CONSPIRACY.
>> Greg: NOT HELPING THAT IS,
THIS IS AN INTERVIEW JAKE TAPPER
DID WITH MS. ABRAMS ABOUT THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE ELECTION.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE WAS
DELIBERATE INTERFERENCE IN THE
ELECTION?
>> YES.
AND I BELIEVE IT BEGAN EIGHT
YEARS AGO WITH THE SYSTEMATIC
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF MORE THAN
A MILLION VOTERS.
>> IS HE A LEGITIMATE
GOVERNOR-ELECT OF GEORGIA?
>> HE IS THE PERSON WHO WON AN
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF VOTES.
SPEAK WITH YOU ARE NOT USING THE
WORD LEGITIMATE.
IS HE THAT LEGITIMATE GOVERNOR
ELECTIVE GEORGIA?
>> HE IS THE LEGAL GOVERNOR OF
GEORGIA.
>> Dana: "THE WEEKLY STANDARD"
HAD AN EDITORIAL TODAY TALKING
ABOUT THE CLAIMS ABOUT THAT
SHE'S MAKING, SHE SAYS THEY WERE
HAPPENING GEORGIA.
IF YOU GO THROUGH THEM ONE BY
ONE, THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO WERE PURGED OFF THE
VOTER ROLLS.
1.5 MILLION.
WHY SO MANY?
PEOPLE WHO DIED, MOVED.
IF THERE IS A LAWSUIT IN 2015
THAT MEANT NO ONE CAME OFF THE
ROLLS THAT YEAR SO THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME YOU SEE IT.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S DOUBLE.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHAT IS GREAT
ABOUT DANA.
I DIDN'T HAVE TO READ THAT
ARTICLE.
>> Dana: I AM SURE JESSE READ
IT BEFORE I DID.
I DO THINK --
>> Jesse: YOU BOUGHT ME THE
SUBSCRIPTION.
I LOVE IT.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT AND
OTHERS WHO WERE SAYING THAT
THERE WAS VOTER FRAUD IN FLORIDA
AND MAY BE IN GEORGIA TOO, THAT
WAS THE SUGGESTION, DEMOCRATS
ARE SAYING THERE IS VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
NEITHER ARE PRESENTING ADEQUATE
EVIDENCE EITHER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS GOING
FORWARD.
I DO THINK ABOUT SOMEONE LIKE
BRENDA SNIPES.
WE CAN MAKE FUN OF HER,
WHATEVER.
LOOKED LIKE SOME INCOMPETENCE
BUT SHE GETS IT DONE IN THE END
AND NOW SHE'S RETIRING.
WHO IS WILLING TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY?
THESE PUBLIC SERVANTS.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
SUPPORT THEM AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH WHAT THEY NEED ON THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED OR WE HAVE
TO GO TO THE ROBOTS.
>> Greg: THE ROBOTS.
I SAY THE ROBOTS.
>> Katie: DID YOU SEE THE
ROBOT ANCHOR THAT CAME OUT IN
CHINA?
IT LOOKED A LOT LIKE YOU, GREG.
>> Greg: I WILL TAKE IT AS A
COMPLIMENT.
I AM VERY SMOOTH.
>> Katie: THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
MAYBE IN GEORGIA BUT ALSO IN
FLORIDA IN TERMS OF THE VOTER
ROLLS NOT BEING CLEANED UP.
BRENDA SNIPES GOT SUED ALSO FOR
HAVING PEOPLE WHO WERE 114 YEARS
OLD ON HER ROLLS, PEOPLE HAD
LEFT THE COUNTY COME ALL THOSE
THINGS.
THE FOLLOW-UP NEEDS TO BE NOT
JUST ONE OF APPOINTING SOMEONE
NEW, BUT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
OFFICE ESPECIALLY IN FLORIDA,
BROWARD AND PALM BEACH COUNTY,
PUSHING THEM TO SAY 2020 IS
COMING.
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR ACTUALLY
DOES UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THINGS ARE
CLEANED UP FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION SO IT DOESN'T COME DOWN
TO TWO COUNTIES THAT HAVE
REPEATEDLY HAVE PROBLEMS FOR A
DECADE MAKING THESE
DETERMINATIONS AND QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHERE THE BALLOTS WERE
FOUND AND WHY THEY'RE BEING
TRANSPORTED IN PRIVATE VEHICLES.
>> Dana: CAN I SAY ONE OF THE
THING ABOUT STACEY ABRAMS?
SHE DID SOMETHING PRETTY
REMARKABLE.
SHE'S A PROGRESSIVE LIBERAL.
SHE CAME PRETTY CLOSE IN GEORGI
GEORGIA.
GEORGIA IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE
OVERNIGHT, BUT SHE SAYS SHE
WANTS TO RUN AGAIN.
CAN SHE FIGURE OUT A WAY, HOW
CAN SHE MAKE UP THOSE 60,000
VOTES OR WHATEVER IT IS?
CAN SHE FIND 60,000 VOTES SO SHE
CAN BECOME THE LEGITIMATE
WINNER.
>> Greg: SHE DID A NICE THING
WHERE SHE SAID BOYCOTTING
GEORGIA IS STUPID.
DON'T DO IT.
SHE DIDN'T ENCOURAGE IT.
>> Juan: NOW YOU HAVE A RUNOFF
OR SECRETARY OF STATE IN GEORGIA
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
EVEN JIMMY CARTER, I GUESS THAT
DOESN'T MEAN MUCH WITH YOU GUYS,
BUT JIMMY CARTER, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAID THAT KEMP SHOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN IN CHARGE OF THE
ELECTION IN WHICH HE WAS
COMPETING.
>> Katie: STACEY ABRAMS
DESERVES CREDIT FOR THE JOB SHE
DID AND BY HER SAYING THAT IT
WAS STOLEN OR THAT THESE THINGS
HAPPEN, SHE'D DELEGITIMIZE AS
ALL OF THE HARD WORK SHE PUT IN
ON THE VOTES SHE GOT.
>> Greg: I WOULD LIKE TO PUT
IN THIS MAY BE THE LAST RECOUNT
SEGMENT WE DOING TWO YEARS.